i watched a film last night with a lot
of us just kind of screaming at the
screen and just loving every moment it
is such an iconic film already to this
point and it must feel so good to
finally put it out there yeah i'm really
excited that it's coming out uh i think
the film is great it's so much fun and
people seem to be uh like you having a
good time with it yeah and you i
understand that you had a fear of flying
and you got into that cockpit and i'm
scared of water
when you're doing that scene i was
freaking out a little bit when you're in
the i don't want to ruin what scene that
is so are you what did he say to calm
your nerves and are you over your fear
now no he didn't say anything actually
you know i i had worked on it before
doing this movie coincidentally just
because it you know i fly a lot so it
was really not sustainable for me to be
feel afraid of flying um
and uh but then it came up and he
mentioned it originally i wasn't
supposed to fly in the movie and he
mentioned that oh you know we're just
going to go up on this p51 and we're
going to do some simple rolls and it's
going to be great and it's tom cruise
he's so cool and i you don't want to not
be you know you want to try to be a
little bit cool so it's not like i'm
saying actually i'm scared of flying um
so
you just say yeah so what was with your
head like were you not freaking out
actually he's so
uh
skilled you see that you know you see
the things that he does he can
go off the edge of a cliff on a
motorcycle you know like up a ramp did
you see that you know these things that
he does that's the least of it for him i
figure flying it you know a plane
so um i felt very capab i felt very
confident in his capabilities
and then you get to do that iconic scene
on the motorcycle with your hair flowing
getting on the back of it with tom
cruise are you like the coolest person
now with all your friends
[Music]
i don't think i'm the coolest person
but it was really fun yeah yeah and it's
really amazing when you're on set well
like you said he's so skillful and he's
able to do things that a lot of people
don't what is something that you learned
for sure for sure what is something that
you learned from him that you just found
just i guess magical well i really
admire uh
his passion for what he does he
clearly loves making movies loves movies
is so appreciative of his fans and
respectful of his fans and really wants
to deliver the best thing he possibly
can
so he's beyond being skilled and you
know really talented he
works really hard and he's so
disciplined and
so committed to what he's doing and i
really admired that
36 years ago a top gun came out i mean
we were babies then and he was given the
name maverick now that you've worked
with him and know tom a little bit more
what nickname would you give him that's
a great nickname yeah you're going to
pick maverick
it's perfect it is perfect isn't it yeah
what makes him an iconic actor
i mean
he's
uh i don't know it's all of that that we
talked about you know he has he has it
innate talent i think but he really
never takes anything for granted it
seemed to me that he never takes
anything for granted and he makes the
most of every opportunity
he's so present he's so charismatic and
just has a really strong presence but on
top of that
i don't know it's the ideas right the
choices that make
actors interesting a lot of the times
and he makes really interesting choices
how would you describe this film in one
word
his film in this film yeah in one word
uh
i think it's fantastic i mean i really i
really do i think it's sort of
it's hard to
distill it into one word but i feel like
you know
if you want to go see a movie sometimes
you want to see a movie that's like a
big hollywood movie that just really
satisfies and delivers and is fun and
it's just like a great time at the
movies and i feel like this movie is so
solid and really does that it's
fantastic it really is it's a good word